welcome to this video wit is bender yeah
the poet the bender from Argentina hmm
okay some English opening probably yeah
looks like it's going to be a hedgehog I
like to play that be three base set up
now d 6 45 here or that move yeah at
least that's something that i can plan
quickly yet this except that i don't
regard as being particularly precise but
it's of course still playable not a
terrible 94 black and i think it's
better for black to put them or keep the
pollen d7 and go for quick knight c6 but
okay that's just a small um theoretical
detail and something that probably you
can argue about so nothing very very
clear let's say um okay so g45 is what
idea here anyway so i'm going ahead with
that quickly yeah I have very fond
memories of that line that's the nine
that was featured in the very first game
where I managed to be the Grand Master
and it even was a pretty strong
grandmaster at the time so what is like
doing now what what has a combination of
them let's say strategically interesting
possession position because of his space
and advantages in center but sometimes
you can actually get a king side attack
and this g-form g5 and so on is
sometimes just used to gain space but in
some
you can really get an attack so will be
interesting to see h6 that's interesting
h4 what is he going to do at age 50 I
don't live in that very much if he goes
h5 I will take it and I don't really see
the compensation otherwise I mean g5
will hit even harder with the palm being
on age 6 a bit of a strange idea unless
I'm not understanding the point we just
have caused entirely possible huh what
is this idea with that yeah that's the
only thing that I could think of but
that will take that pawn I'm not going
to go g5 and allow Knight to g4 and well
rook g1 King somewhere and then the g
file is kind of dangerous if you look at
that bishop on be too that's not going
to be easy to player for black Oh what
is the idea Queen Queen a age or
something along these lines I can go
Knight to c6 I'm not sure what if that
helps much but ok let's put the King on
the side here a queen I mean cooking age
3 was a bit tricky as long ok that was
to be expected but I can move the Queen
I mean like a queen I was thinking Queen
g3 but he can actually then take Oh
interesting maybe that wasn't the most
precise way to play then
you know what's funny even the move 95
might be possible here 95 85 night f5
that's probably rather dangerous rather
dangerous is probably let's play that
it's just confirm what I think I hadn't
planned that beforehand but it's it's
very dangerous e 7 hangs bishop is is
opened now the p2 bishop and I'm ready
for a rook g1 or queen Queen on the G
file now that's not going to work I
don't think that black can withstand
that pressure but maybe maybe you find
some idea so Luke g1 was the simple idea
okay little counter pinning idea mm-hmm
that's something that I should have paid
more attention to definitely hmm it's
very unfortunate
yeah it's a problem with the King on age
3 m I should have probably put it
somewhere else
jaja hmm how do I cover that a 59 I mean
average g5 but it's not not a super
attractiveness really that's surprising
hard to believe that black can't afford
that one but maybe he can maybe he can
but ok so i need to need the Queen near
the whole action and I have to move that
cannot operate you with that pin all the
time so I wants to go nitey form him
that's not winning her amazingly enough
tick tick tick see 394 Bishop g4 is
going to check the area on the second
rank time warning
nice going back Wow okay that i didn't
expect check
maybe uk2 in order to take on a one or
something I don't know
I do I don't really have a threat that's
a it's a problem here really okay now no
I'm threatening rook on g7 I guess just
some what I am okay after Queen takes a
knee as rook g8 huh funny oks tell e
seven is still hanging I was 12 seconds
I mean this is still super dangerous 97
and everything I chapter don't think he
will defend that check okay he's giving
away most of his material I can take
take d6 for Luke h6 check let's meet on
a jade black forfeits on time now I play
I didn't play that well I mean here
white is certainly winning but I miss
played that quite a bit so let's let's
start here mineralogy it's outside of it
here why just why just has a much better
position not sure if you could call it a
win but it's probably very close they
would would tortoise to confuse ero
point eight okay but him this is
probably a no maybe that's not the most
precise way to play it I don't know here
and no angeles is very it's just
advocating this very simple solution
which is of course strong yeah it's very
structure you just take the second porn
and black and basically yeah resign now
just the wood structures also breaking
down okay yeah it was very simple but
this looked very attractive so and it
seems to win as well by the way
the engines on +1 on depth 20 and this
is the kind of thing if it if you give
it more time the evaluation probably
will climb up yeah here wide is winning
so Queen Jeter was winning I really I
really overlooked this Queen d7 idea but
add 75 no wins and set of root g 5y
which is keeping it an edge but this
seems to just flat-out win hmm what is
the problem what is the threat our queen
g2 intending Quincy fire that's very
strong it's very strong this is a maid
check check check check check mate it's
nice mmhmm yeah g5 takes and yeah this
was rook d6 was a complete win yeah I
was very I wasn't really sharp
technically in that game check check
Janet's going to be made here yeah it's
funny the engine it says this is about
equal I know it gives black a slight
advantage and here chakia black should
win with the cam show yeah I can do that
I wanted to do this attending those
sorry those mates but he has this chair
after which King g one g eight will win
for him Jackie that was the problem
ready oh I gotta keep getting a call ok
well thanks for watching